I had to grow up fast because I was
alone
[Music]
every single time to step outside a
house there's a chance to pin the
diamond that day you don't know I've
never interviewed anyone like this
before
a 14-year old boy with a story of
neglect gang life and a care system that
seems to have lost
[Music]
[Music]
after his parents broke up Ben spent
three years in care but was then sent
back to live with his father who turned
out to be abusive under lockdown the
pressure got too much and he ran away
the day before this interview the police
took him home after he'd been missing
for six weeks but already he's run away
again what did they say to your father
and what he father say to them no just
like this is the best place for me to be
you know which really annoyed me because
they didn't know the full story he just
met me he didn't
and what did you dad say my dad didn't
he say anything he just said all right
he won't really bother to be honest he
wasn't bothered was he interested in
where you'd been but he didn't ask why
he didn't ask he's been away for six
weeks need him ask where you've been he
didn't notice
[Music]
he'd been dosing at a flat of a
convicted criminal and although shocking
this story is becoming too typical as
hundreds of children are dropping off
the radar the Children's Society told us
they're receiving numerous reports of
children going listening for longer and
since the virus high-risk children have
become even high risk
you have a social worker do they know
where you are
no do they know how long you've been
missing for from your family yeah they
do you're in contact with them yeah how
often northen anymore I mean I think the
social workers feel like they've done
their job as long as I'm alive they're
still doing their job if you're alive
yeah what are they doing to help make
that happen my honestly don't know we
all have got social workers we do have
police you know people are out there
he's passed through them they've met him
they've spoken to him and what have they
done
they've passed the responsibility on to
the father who's abusing and it's been
abandoned so what do you do you go and
find the family on the street which is
gangs drug-dealing knife crime you know
gun crime and then we wonder as a
society how we let a generation fall I
know you have have had get gang
affiliation is that because you you feel
like you you're looking for a family I
grew up in an area I've seen all my
friends I've seen a couple of people die
I've known a couple of people I've
dieted on shorts you know being stabbed
but to me that's just some normal day in
the neighborhood
so what does it do to you how does it
change you
I mean he just changes your mind song
life you're gonna have to carry on my
visa comes with you just so you know
you're safe when you leave your house
but at the same time as it also if you
do a shoo-in or a stabbing people know
but you must be messed with
people want that respect so the only way
we get them respects by doing don't work
[Music]
then doesn't want us to name his gang
but it's one that has seen several
members killed and others put in prison
for murder by the age of twelve he was
in the thick of it did you carry a knife
yeah it's carry a knife and I did all
those things yeah yeah yeah to protect
myself but if I didn't I'd be dead to be
quite frank and did you ever carry a gun
people in the gang they're smart so
don't hold it gonna walk in they may
carry in the car a lot the times I've
been in the car with friends that have a
gun on them yeah you know just in case
you see someone in that position Co
group you could jump out on them and
shoot or stab them or just hop back in
the car and then just make sure you're
naming tie to the car do you ever not
just think I'm a kid you know I am too
young for all of this
[Music]
like most kids Ben isn't going to school
right now and charities fear that with
schools closed there's a new way of
vulnerable children who are out of sight
our biggest concerns are children
becoming invisible the office natural
radar not being known to schools to
social services and essentially losing
their voice amongst this pandemic I mean
either strengthen your I've got a 14 mil
daughter who wouldn't have a clue about
life do would you reduce what places
with someone like that and say I don't
want this or you feel like you're you
are where you are yeah I feel like I am
I am there's a reason why I'm you know
needing this life I know that it ended
the day people just say gang life ends
up leaving you dead or in prison and
sometimes yeah it does while the times a
gives you a good result through music
and other things people get involved in
this gang life because they know what
they're doing
Mardon a couple of stab wounds here in
the store
and then think about how the sky
affiliation could turn your life into
something you actually want my money you
know providing for your family that's
what certain people when you scan life
it's not all about you seeing opposition
and trying to kill them though you're 14
yeah I know something goes bad in my
life I've had to change in myself no one
else is gonna change a form
do you see yourself as a as a vulnerable
child
nada you don't how do you see yourself
as a fortunate kid had to grow up fast
to keep up
and you still haven't gone
you